morning victims have waited decades for
this day to see a former prime minister
questioned over the government's
response to the infected blood scandal
the evidence i shall give shall be the
truth shall be the truth the whole truth
the whole truth
but far from any apology or admission of
guilt there was instead a comment seen
as offensive sir john major describing
what happened as bad luck
there's no amount of compensation you
can give that could actually compensate
for what had happened to them what had
happened to them was
incredibly
bad luck
many clearly disagree
and and the scandal saw up to 5 000 nhs
patients infected with hiv or hepatitis
c after being given contaminated blood
products in the 70s and 80s around 3000
of whom have since died
among them is nikki calder infected with
hiv before he was 10 during treatment
for hemophilia he died aged 25. i try
not to be angry
and i try not to be bitter
it was very difficult
but rosemary says that anger is much
harder to suppress when listening to
comments such as sir john's
bad luck is when you trip over a paving
stone and break your leg or something
bad luck isn't when you go when you say
to somebody oh bad luck you've been
given a a potentially life-threatening
virus
that's not bad luck
we want people to just stand up and say
we did wrong
no government has taken responsibility
for the scandal and it was the same
again today sir john major defending his
roles in margaret thatcher's cabinets
and his own and the refusal to award
compensation
everyone in this room can think of a
dozen things where you could argue
someone has a moral obligation to do
something
and
the government has to keep control of
events
and keep control of the sum total
expenditure
throughout his evidence sir john major
was at pains to say the government was
not unsympathetic to victims and that
the decision against compensation was
purely practical to avoid setting a
potentially costly precedent but it's an
argument victims simply aren't buying
he's telling a story and i think he
believes it because what he believes is
that there was no liability at the time
but he never investigated it and his uh
his government never investigated it or
if they did they didn't tell anyone what
the outcome of that investigation was so
yes the victims that firmly believed
there was a cover-up
the inquiry is expected to conclude
later this year three years after it
began as their numbers continue to
dwindle victims and their families hope
it will finally bring justice before
it's too late iva bennett sky news